all the ways style and Will Smith he is
still getting jiggy on stage and only
our Kevin Frazier has this Fresh Prince
exclusive and he joins us now for one
mysterious location hi there kids
Nancy looks like I could be in New
Jersey an Atlantic City or maybe your
home of Myrtle Beach but actually I'm in
northern England
Blackpool it's a resort town but last
night it was the home of a rap reunion
that was nearly two decades in the
making
we'll reteamed with former partner DJ
Jazzy Jeff and had the British crowd
going wild what took y'all so long we've
been doing other things right you've
been doing other things Jeff Jeff is on
tour for like 200 days out the year so I
just you know I've been I've been
waiting for the moment you know and it's
this feel this felt like the time with
will center stage and Jeff working the
beats these two haven't lost a step
since back in the 80s when they were DJ
Jazzy Jeff and The Fresh Prince that was
wills buddy LL Cool J who suggested it
was time for will to hit the road again
he's like it's time you have no idea
the love that that's out there and I was
like listening to Elle's I okay alright
I need to do it I need to do it
the two performed in Croatia the night
before and this show was part of an MTV
Music Festival besides slaying the crowd
will also helped our crew with the
cameras baby c-calm in mine
everybody's like album's coming world
tours coming here comes everything so
now what well I'm happy we got to two
shows now I got the buggers the first
first time really being on stage in a
while I blew my voice out a little I do
that all the time but I just can't
contain myself on stage that's my that's
my Nancy
sending it back to you thank you very
much well good rat they're double
meaning all right well no word yet more
concert dates we'll have to work through
his movies schedule first he's so
multi-talented Izzy yes he is that ll
was right though there's still a lot of
love out there oh you know it absolutely